so there are people not just a few
people but quite a number of people who
are sitting in solitary confinement
tonight in the dc
jail charged with trespassing and yet
tony fauci
is not only free and unindicted
uninvestigated
but he's running around basking in the
love on cable tv shows
what's the difference well possibly tony
fauci knows how to use the media and if
you watched msnbc last night you saw the
surreal interview he did with jeb bush's
former flak
really it's hard to believe that
actually happened over at cnn one anchor
at least tried to make his interview
with tony fauci look legitimate he asked
fouchy why some of his emails were
heavily redacted
in fact she just laughed in his face an
email exchange between you
and nih director francis collins the
email sent to you
said conspiracy theory gains momentum
and this again was the idea of the lab
leak those emails though as you can see
on the screen or i can see on the screen
was all redacted between you and francis
collins do you happen to remember
do you remember john
they only took about 10 000 emails from
me of course i remember i remember all
10 000 of them
give me a break but to be clear you're
saying you don't remember
you can't tell us what what was in the
body of that i i don't remember what's
in that redacted
but there i mean the idea i think
is quite far-fetched that the chinese
deliberately engineered something so
that they could kill themselves
as well as other people i i i think
that's a bit far out
it wasn't much of an interview to put it
mildly
but that's not tony fatchi's official
response he's not going to say anything
over on msnbc he was to be fair pressed
harder
by someone who's actually smart and
fauci refused to discuss whether china
might have a
motive to cover up a lab leak
you say it's in china's interest though
would you agree though dr fauci is
in their interest to hide it if there
was a lab leak or worse if they were
designing something in their lab so that
the world that america didn't know that
it came out of their own lab wouldn't
they want to conceal that
you know willie i don't want to be
speculating on that because every time i
say something like that it you know it
as well as i
it will get completely taken out of
context and go into the twitter world
like
crazy so i mean i'm going to leave that
to other people and not
surmise and guess whose interest it is
it's not helpful
miranda devine is a columnist with the
new york post she joins us tonight
miranda thanks so much for coming on i
you know you hate to keep grousing about
the media
um because it does get repetitive but
this is something that actually matters
because if we don't know where the virus
came from we can't prevent another
pandemic
and you know we could probably save
lives if we figured this out at what
point are we going to get to the bottom
of this will the media decide you know
enough of this nonsense tony fauci
answer the freaking question
well i i don't know if they ever will i
think anthony fauci has been very clever
at
shaping the media uh particularly on
this pandemic story i mean he knew
from day one that there were reputable
scientists who
believed that this was a man-made virus
he also knew
that he had been funding gain of
function this frankenstein research
to juice up bat coronaviruses in the
wuhan lab
specifically to get around the obama
administration
ban anthony fauci was probably the
world's
greatest fan greatest supporter of this
dangerous gain of function research and
there were hundreds of american
scientists
who thought it was too dangerous to
persist with they convinced the obama
administration to lift to the ban
then tony fauci took advantage of the
new
trump administration in their early days
in 2017
to go and tell them that there was
nothing dangerous they'd done a review
and to lift that moratorium
and he is uh you know if this is a lab
leak
that's why he has a vested interest the
last thing he
wants is for anybody in the media to
come close
to saying if this is a lab leak are you
responsible for the research that
resulted in that lab leak
he doesn't want that the other person
who's very conflicted is the man
whose sub agency whose non-profit in new
york
at the nih through anthony fauci was
funding that's peter dazek
from eco health alliance and like
anthony fauci
he's very powerful in terms of shaping
the narrative you just talked about the
lancet
article that he engineered
and also he was the only american person
on the world health organization
investigation
whitewash into what happened in the lab
yeah this i i hope that you keep pushing
and i knew that you have been miranda
divine you and a few others to get to
the bottom of this because
it has profound consequences not just
for understanding our past but for the
future this this is frankenstein's stuff
and it should stop immediately
i appreciate it thank you thanks tucker
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else